so uh just as a tiny bit of introduction
mentorship can be defined in a lot of
different ways
but the way i think about it anyway is
that it it it
encompasses a lot of things mentors can
be your advisors or pis
uh who are formally responsible for your
academic progress it can be supporters
of your personal and professional
endeavors
teachers even trainers
maybe you have sponsors and allies
um
maybe you have academic role models as
future faculty and leaders beyond the
academy really anyone who you can find
who can help you reach your professional
goals
so um
on the flip side we expect you our
students to
weave together the network you need of
resources and advisors
and so that you can pursue your
intellectual and professional goals
and your needs from mentors will vary of
course across your disciplines and the
type of degree you're working on as well
as where you are in your program what
you need as a beginning student will
change over time as you make progress
however that and there are some things
some shared values and goals and
responsibilities that really underpin
all effective mentorship relationships
and those include
the need to be self-directed to be
really intrinsically motivated and to be
able to persevere through
rough spots because we all have those
and if you can do that and reach out
you can definitely find supportive
scholars and friends to make your
graduate education
wonderful in a collaborative way
you are definitely not alone yale is
teaming with advisors and mentors and
you know that's includes faculty of
course but also deans and staff advanced
students peers
really this is this is a people to
people-to-people endeavor we're doing
and you should tap into
all the help you can get
so today we're focusing on a particular
type of uh
mentorship and that's exemplified in the
grad school by our annual graduate
mentor awards and these celebrate
faculty members who have been
outstanding teachers and advisors of
graduate students
and the three faculty members who are
here today on the panel are all past
winners of the graduate mentor award um
which means they were nominated by their
current or past or both uh mentees for
this award for their exemplary behaviors
so they really exemplify the important
qualities
to which
all graduate teachers and faculty
mentors should aspire
so just brief introductions um gary
bredwick is the silliman professor of
chemistry
and professor bradvig's students have
remarked that somehow he manages
to um
sorry i lost my place by moving my
screen around
um somehow he manages to be inspiring
and scientifically challenging at the
same time without being intimidating or
demanding
he allows his mentees to use their time
in graduate school to develop as
scientists and people in the ways we
find most value we find most valuable
one student wrote quote this is a quote
of course the chemistry is always the
main goal but gary also encourages
students to spend time taking extra
classes gaining teaching skills and
leading outreach efforts i think the
best way to sum up what makes gary such
a great advisor and mentor is that he
allows for each of his students to have
the flexibility to follow their own
passions so gary thanks for being here
my pleasure
next um kelly schue is professor of
finance at the school of management
professor shua is known to go above and
beyond to support her phd advisor
advisees
students note that she cares deeply
about their personal and professional
success and does everything she can to
help them reach their full potential as
scholars
one student remarked quote in a year
when many academic conferences have been
cancelled or gone virtual professor shua
tried to make up for the lost networking
opportunities by connecting students
with other faculty members who do work
in the same fields she will go the extra
mile for her advisees thanks for being
here and thanks for being for for all of
that
and our third faculty member here with
us today is joanne meyerowitz who's the
the arthur anobski professor of history
and professor of american studies
professor meyerwitz's students esteem
her as a dream advisor who teaches
students to read history while
sharpening their abilities to identify
trends in historical scholarship
one nominator wrote that she is quote
timely and thoughtful in her engagement
with student work frank about the
rewards and difficulties of the academic
job market and consistently helpful in
directing her students toward resources
and opportunities to develop their
scholarship and intellectual community
so thank you all three of you
as exceptional mentors for providing
insights today to to students and anyone
else who's tuned in
we are lucky to have you here thank you
for doing it
um
so that's uh so now what i'd like to do
is hand the floor over to assistant dean
for graduate student life matthew taneko
who will moderate the con discussion
so please enjoy everyone
thank you lynn
um i just want to reiterate dean
cooley's gratitude for our panelists
participation this afternoon
um so we'll start with a few questions
that we've prepared in advance for our
panelists and we'll reserve the latter
part of the panel for a q a from the
audience so feel free to put questions
in the chat i'll do my best to include
questions as they come up in the
discussion um but you can also save
questions till the end and use the
raised hand feature um to ask those live
um
so i wanted to say that the word mentor
takes its etymological origin from the
character mentor in the odyssey
and mentor was the teacher and advisor
to odysseus's son telemachus after
odysseus left for the trojan war
so let's just say that mentorship is an
ancient practice but to be effective it
also must account for contemporary
issues
and so i hope that today's discussion
will address the current needs of both
mentors and mentees within higher
education to build the kinds of
effective mentorship relationships that
lin was describing earlier
so i want to start off the conversation
by asking each of our faculty panelists
to talk about their personal mentoring
philosophies and how they've adapted
their practices to the current realities
of graduate education which is both the
realities of the pandemic but also the
changing nature of what graduate
education is for
so i open the floor up to whomever wants
to begin with
the discussion
well okay i'll just jump right in um
so i would say that basically i i see my
role as an advocate and a supporter of
the students who i advise and who are in
my classes
but you know as an advocate who's
willing to push who's willing to um
suggest ways to navigate the institution
and especially to suggest ways to
improve um
to improve scholarship you know i
believe in sort of giving honest and
kind uh constructive
feedback but again let me emphasize the
honest part i think it's really
important to to be honest at the same
time as kind and constructive
and i'd say that my aim is to work with
students to accomplish what they want to
accomplish to help them accomplish what
they want to accomplish and that means
listening to what they want
which isn't necessarily what necessarily
what i think should be you know the
topic of their scholarship or whatever
that's really up to the students i work
with and my goal is to help them reach
their goals
so and sometimes occasionally that means
intervening being a mediator on their
behalf
say
intervening with other faculty members
or back when i was at dgs intervening
with deans
but only if a student requests that kind
of mediation that seems really important
to me to respect a certain kind of um
you know within the law certain kind of
confidentiality
um and you asked about change over time
too about sort of the the recent recent
changes and i would say that
more recently um i've been giving more
attention to non-academic careers as we
all have and the possibilities for that
and listening to what it is that
students
want to do with their lives and that
could mean following a non-academic
trajectory after getting a phd it could
mean dropping out before getting a phd i
have students who've
chosen to
forego the dissertation and go be a
labor organizer or go be a high school
teacher and you know sometimes they
think that they're disappointing me in
doing that and i my i want to reassure
them that it's not a disappointment it's
i want them to flourish i want them to
do what they want to do and i want to
support them in whatever that is
um and whatever they've learned at yale
you know they'll they'll that will shape
will inform their lives after yale
whatever the career is
and finally i would say that i pay more
attention now to mental health issues um
i think that we're all becoming more
aware just of just how hard graduate
school can be
i'm happy to follow up um
so
i i try to
actually
follow and get a read on what the
student would like
in terms of a mentoring relationship
and i think
graduate students are highly
idiosyncratic some people want a really
high touch relationship in which
i check in on them regularly they touch
in with me regularly i think that can be
a very effective um other people can do
very well with more
more kind of formal meetings or check in
via email and if that's their preferred
mode of contact i think that can still
work
i think the benefit of a university
environment is we can handle all kinds
of personalities and preferences
for mentoring relationships and also
research styles
so i i'm a professor in the finance
group at yale som
and within the research disciplines of
finance economics et cetera we don't
really run labs it's really there's
students with
who are doing their independent research
projects they might sometimes co-author
with faculty
but they're not tied to any particular
faculty member through a laboratory
relationship
i think because of that i try very hard
not to be
territorial over students
in fact i really encourage them to find
multiple mentors
partly so too so that they can get
multiple points of view
but also kind of diversifies their risk
in terms of what if one faculty member
moves or gives advice that ends up not
being um
useful or let's say a student wants to
work on something interdisciplinary so
they really need to make a committee of
people with multiple areas of expertise
matthew had also asked about adapting to
modern demands especially with a
pandemic
what i've tried to do is
i offer students to meet over zoom or in
my office some people actually prefer
the convenience of meeting over zoom
doesn't require that they're on campus
especially if they have family
responsibilities or they're stuck in
another country
and i've tried to be a
more ex more
more of a listener in terms of their
just other problems in their lives you
know it's important i think that i don't
probe too much or ask
but a lot of these problems do just come
up in conversation i think it's very
useful actually for me to know just the
context of their these research problems
but then that's in a context of a whole
set of issues that my students are
dealing with
yeah i guess i can follow suit so um so
i'm in the chemistry department and we
work in a lab as a team so i'll talk
more in terms of you know the the
mentoring in a in that kind of an
environment um you know
you graduate school is a transition
point where you go from being an
undergraduate where you take courses and
you you learn and you reiterate things
that are you know in the courses to
independent research where you're
blazing your own trail and you're you're
doing independent work um and you're not
following directions anymore and so my
goal is to facilitate that
and and as joanne said to achieve your
goals in in the end and that those goals
might be to become an academic or maybe
to work in industry maybe to become you
know a consultant lots of different
directions go to law school those are
all directions students from my group
have have taken um
and
yeah so
within a team environment um you know so
one of the things i i really work to do
is to encourage uh team efforts and and
people working together um and that
creates a a level of interaction and
engagement that um i think leads to less
isolation in a in a team effort um
you're not on your own you're really
working as a team but on the other hand
everyone has to follow their own path
and become independent and and learn how
to do that
and that that that's my goal um
and
encouraging independent ideas i'm i'm
pretty much a hands-off
advisor and so i'm not looking every day
okay do this next do that next um but
really we talk
uh
as a group every week many times a week
actually and and you know it's to
brainstorm together and and work towards
a successful path forward um and so that
that's my idea of mentorship and
you know i think uh the pandemic has has
has put certainly put it made it more
difficult for in-person um engagement
but on the other hand it's also by using
zoom as an opportunity to have frequent
face-to-face connections yeah my one of
my challenges is my research group is
split um part of my group is in the
chemistry department on main campus and
the rest of my group is on the west
campus and the energy science institute
you know and so it's not always so easy
to see each other face to face all the
time because you back and forth travel
but zoom actually makes that a lot
easier so there are some benefits to
you know the transition to zoom we'll
probably not stop doing that um
even when things get more back to normal
thank you all that's great i think
there's a clear sense of having a
student-centered approach and giving the
students independence while either
connecting them with resources or
enabling them to pursue those resources
on their own that really comes through
in all of your answers
um
there is currently a trend
in student affairs to talk about the
whole person approach and that it's
impossible to completely separate out
our personal and professional lives
and yet
boundaries are necessary to maintain
healthy interpersonal interactions
across the board
so could you talk a bit about how you
maintain healthy relationships with your
mentees and what advice you would give
students for setting and respecting
boundaries with their mentors
i guess i don't know if we want to
follow the same sequence every time but
i'll go this way we'll break the trend
and we can mix it up a little bit uh but
i was going to mention this before but
um please
ask questions i i'm more than happy to
be interrupted and and if you have any
questions you want to follow up or just
ask something uh um please do so i i
think um i think matt's looking at the
chat if you want to do that you know add
something to the chat um yeah you know
so
as i mentioned you know
in a in a science group we work as a
team um and and most of the time that is
you know quite professional we're
working on research talking about you
know new results new plans for
experiments and so on but it also
creates kind of a family uh and and we
do things together and and so you know
it's not a complete division between you
know the science that we do and you know
other things out of the outside of the
lab as well so i think that's something
that that is is a good aspect of a team
that works in a lab and that um
and for example you know my own research
group they they organized game nights
during uh when we were shut down with uh
with covid and so we did that on zoom
and that was that was fun uh and not
just actually about a month ago we had a
group ski trip and so yeah we do we do
some of those kind of things just to
you know foster a team effort and and so
um
but then you know i think everybody has
their own personal life and and that's
separate uh so you know
separate from the group so and that's an
important boundary yeah that i think i i
respect
yeah i would agree that there there are
definitely boundaries to respect i think
that when i was i mean i work more
one-on-one with people not in a lab
setting so it's not that sort of same
group team building spirit except in the
classroom
and i think that when i was younger i
felt you know when i was much younger i
felt more like a friend or a peer with
some of my students with my graduate
students some of whom were actually
older than i was way back then but now
i'm older and i i feel
friendly but not like a friend and so i
feel it's more of a professional
relationship
and you know i don't um expect to be
part of my students personal lives
unless i'm explicitly invited to be you
know invited to meet a partner or
parents or um or go to a wedding or
something like that so but mostly
professional and i i would say i like to
make myself available uh to meet with
advisees and students but you know that
you know and i'm always happy to go out
for coffee or have lunch but usually
that's in a campus setting not always
but almost always in a campus setting
again that sort of professional feeling
to it
um and i and and i know that there can
be a kind of fine line between mentoring
and surveillance
and i want to be careful not to cross
that line i don't want anybody to feel
like i'm monitoring them or invading
their lives and so really it's more of a
expecting students to come to me when
they need something from me or want
something from me and to make clear that
i'm i'm a presence there for them when
they need me but not a constant presence
in their lives
yeah i
for me personally this has so far not
been much of an issue um although i do
have mixed views on on this question in
general um so personally i maintain a
fairly professional relationship with my
mentees
what i've noticed is that after they
graduate we'll continue talking but then
we move toward a less of a professional
relationship and we can talk more as
colleagues and friends
but that typically happens after
graduation when my students get their um
their first jobs um
i do have mixed views on this because
i know there's research showing that
i think the research is about the
unequal
access to schmoozing and how much
schmoozing matters for career
advancement
but i do worry that the
the knee-jerk reaction to this research
is then we're going to we're just going
to ban all channels for schmoozing so
faculty are perhaps not going to be
allowed to invite students to their
homes for parties or we can't have meals
with students because well if we can't
have offer the same opportunity to all
students then we just shouldn't do it at
all
and i'm not sure that's the right way to
go
instead it really has to be about
students have to match with the with the
set of faculty that they choose and they
have a good match with and part of that
is through perhaps more informal
activities and talking about more than
just research anyway so i'm not sure
where the right balance is
but i would hope that we don't
completely ban or rule out these
opportunities as a school
oh that's helpful
um
building on that sort of
how you approach these relationships and
build out these relationships um i think
knowing what you want and asking for
what you need and knowing the difference
between those two things
is an essential piece of it um and so
negotiation clear communication these
are the things that are crucial to
making
that relationship successful
um so what advice would you give to
students for actually communicating with
their mentors effectively and whether
that's in meetings or
via email or how often they should be um
speaking with their mentors
and i'm thinking also here more broadly
than just the faculty advisor to student
relationship right i think we're getting
at something here which is that
you're building a sort of culture around
yourself in some of these relationships
and figuring out who to ask for when and
so do you all have any advice around
sort of how to do that effectively with
the communication
uh one one thing that i tell all my
students to do is um maybe this applies
more for students for which on their
dissertations it's really their job to
come up with a completely independent
topic as is the case in finance and
economics
what i tell them is when they ask
faculty for feedback on research ideas
is to
ask them really to rank
three ideas or rank more than one idea
and the idea
behind this advice is we would like to
give honest feedback
but we also want to be nice and
supportive people
so oftentimes if a student just comes
comes to our office with one idea we're
going to try to get as much out of that
idea as possible even if
you know that idea may face various
hurdles to publication or job market
success
so
coming to our office hours or coming to
talk to us with three possible avenues
of research or our specialization
just allows us to give give more
honest and helpful feedback
so i guess if um my main piece of advice
would be
to
stay in touch to don't disappear
um so i think that
mentors and faculty advisors and
professors don't want to feel like we
have to chase after you to find out
how you're doing
so that may sometimes be that i'll take
the initiative and get in touch with
people but generally i expect students i
work with to
let me know how they're doing and i
don't mean on a weekly basis or daily
basis i just mean you know make sure
they staying in touch and letting me
know what's going on in their uh not in
their personal lives but in their
professional lives and if need be in
their personal lives as well
so if they choose so i i think that that
staying in touch is um
it's not just about coming to someone
when you have a problem
although that's a really important thing
to do
but i think also to share your triumphs
with your professors um to you know what
are you accomplishing where are you you
know you
your mentors want to hear about the hard
spots you're having but you know your
mentors will take great pride in your
accomplishments i mean i can't tell you
i feel real joy when uh one of my
students has some great accomplishment
and i want them to let me know so i
guess it's a matter of
maintaining a conversation
across time and not not again daily not
necessarily weekly but just staying in
touch i think that's really important
when there's a problem and even when
there's not
i guess it's a little bit different in
the sciences it's not that we're not
staying in touch i mean i meet with
everybody in my group every week
multiple times
but i'm not a mind reader yeah so i
don't know you know what your problems
might be
uh things that you're that you'd like
advice on you have to ask and uh you
know so i think
you know setting up meetings and
discussing
any topic you want i mean it could be
ranging from a different research
uh direction versus a career pathway uh
or
um
any aspect in your career development
you have yeah yeah
i can i can tell you things but it may
not be what you're really you know
concerned about or or need advice on so
i think asking and you know in my own
case i i have a went well before covet
an open door policy now i guess an open
contact policy whether it's a zoom
meeting or you know an email or what um
and yeah i think encourage that you know
as joanne said you you've got you know
stay in touch you know
tell us what what you're you're you're
thinking and what you need you know
you'd like to you know
us to give advice on
i can't help but think about my own time
in graduate school and particularly with
what joanne was saying where sometimes
you have a problem and you don't want to
bring it up and the longer you keep it
from the conversation the worse it gets
and you just kind of build this anxiety
around it and i think that's so
important what all of you are saying
here about just keeping the constant
conversation going
um we're getting a couple of questions
in the chat so i'm going to switch gears
a little bit and sort of encourage those
because we're here to help students
think through the questions that they
have so the first question that we
received was i'd love to hear our guests
reflection on advice for students who
have co-advisors for a dissertation in
situations where they have
they have been a co-advisor what has
worked best for you in this situation
any tips for students in this situation
we have been sort of thinking about
developing a relationship but sometimes
there are multiple people in that
relationship so which adds complication
of course
i can lead into that because uh the
research we do is very collaborative and
in fact we've had a
collaborative project with several other
faculty members in in the chemistry
department and so
we had many formally co-advised students
and most of them are informally but we
meet as a team every week and so uh yeah
i think
it's important to to be consistent on on
what you're saying when of course we may
raise questions about
interpretations and maybe that's a
little bit different from one advisor to
the other but we have to be consistent
in our uh you know in our support and
advice on that otherwise there could be
trouble and you know so that works you
need to work together on that um but but
um
i think it could it could be
um i think one thing that facilitates
that is that we meet as you know as as a
team and have roundtable discussion
every week so we can sort of make sure
everybody's working on the same in the
same direction
so i do a lot of co-advising um i think
probably
i haven't counted but maybe more than
half of the dissertations i've advised
here have been co-advised and i i think
it's it's really not problematic i think
it's a great thing um usually it's um
but we're not working in a team in a lab
and so usually um an advisee has
independent relationships with each of
the co-advisors and gets independent
feedback from them and occasionally
sometimes that's nicely reinforcing
we're all saying the same thing
you know you you you need to reorganize
in this way and we both say the same
thing and that's great and sometimes we
say different things and that makes for
interesting conversation
and i don't think anybody expects you
to sort of
you know
favor one or the other but to follow
your own guidance and if there's
conflicting advice to talk it out and
then do what you want to do and what you
need to do so i i think it's i don't
think that it's ever really been a
problematic thing and i think it's nice
for somebody to have more than one
person who they feel like is their
their main advisor so that there's not
just one person who who is responsible
for giving uh
quick feedback and advice
basically every student that i've been
advised it's always been co-advising
that's just kind of the structure of
dissertation committees within finance
and economics
one problem here is that oftentimes the
advisors do ask the students to go in
different directions and then the
student is unclear about how to proceed
you know i think there it would really
be helpful if the student explained to
each advisor
how the other advisors are
are
what the other advisors are suggesting
because one problem that i've seen
emerge is
you know we i've heard this from other
faculty members we'll meet with a
student recommend some direction a month
later the student hasn't done anything
regarding our suggestion
and that actually could be because the
other faculty members are suggesting
something else
um but it'd be really helpful if we
understood that rather than thinking oh
it's because you've chosen to do nothing
over over the course of a month um
another strategy that has worked is when
the student
arranges for an internal presentation
all the dissertation members are present
and and this could be done before kind
of formally scheduled presentation dates
and that way all the committee members
are in one room and can kind of hash out
the differences in their suggested
directions
thank you um there are plenty of
questions coming in now so i'm just
going to keep running through them could
you all speak to the unique challenges
and perhaps opportunities and benefits
of being a mentor as a tenure track
professor as opposed to a tenured
professor with more job security i'm
particularly curious about time
management and i'd appreciate any
thoughts you have about this i think
this is really important as students are
becoming mentors themselves as well and
becoming faculty
yeah i i can maybe jump in on that uh
yeah i think
there's a lot of pressure for junior
faculty members you know to be
productive and and and make a name for
themselves and make tenure and sometimes
they put undue pressure on their
students and i think i think that's
something that you have to be careful
about
and i think that
sometimes can be
leading to very difficult arrangements
and
i know in my case probably was no
exception but i i really did try to look
into the direction of the student rather
than my own
you know individual
interests but you know there's there are
realities and demands too and you know
getting getting the results for the next
grant proposal and we all work as a team
to you know to try to work on that and
sometimes that can be stressful but i
think again you know working together as
opposed to
you know making demands is is a good
strategy
um within my area of finance and
economics research i would say there's
i mean it's unfortunate but there's just
no incentive for junior faculty to be
effective mentors or to devote a lot of
time to it many of them are but i think
that's because they're intrinsically
motivated and they just like research
and talking about that with students but
there's
there's almost nothing in it for them in
terms of
higher pr tenure probability um because
we don't work in labs mentoring students
has no direct benefit to our own
research
it's really about you know many people
do just like to engage with students and
i think as students you should try to
seek out those people
but the way the institution is designed
junior faculty have entirely the wrong
set of
incentives
so
it's been a long time since i've been a
junior faculty member but um i don't
recall it being any different in terms
of the kind of mentoring i did
there was a sense in which
junior faculty sometimes can't be a
dissertation advisor maybe they can be a
co-advisor in some departments but they
can't be the advisor
just because of some some of the rules
we have and sometimes because
graduate students feel closer to people
who are closer to their age and develop
relationships with them they sometimes
lean on junior faculty
in ways as if they're advisors and then
that faculty junior faculty member
doesn't get credit for being the advisor
because isn't the advisor so i've heard
that from junior faculty members here so
i think you know to be careful of to to
acknowledge
that untenured professors need to
protect their research time and might
not be getting credit for being
dissertation advisors uh even though
they're offering a kind of mentorship so
i think that's something to be aware of
but i think that actual mentoring the
kinds of mentoring we do i don't think
it's all that different before you have
tenure and after you have tenure
thank you i want to throw in a sort of
follow-up which is one of the topics
that we had um
and it's around sort of building your
own mentorship as faculty members and
how that's changed over your careers
because i think that's somewhat related
to this question or i'm imagining that
this question is partially about
students becoming faculty members and
then both mentoring graduate students of
their own but i think it's important to
remember that mentorship does not exist
in graduate school alone right and that
this is something that will continue to
happen so does anyone want to speak to
sort of how you've continued to
cultivate these sorts of relationships
with colleagues and friends and others
um yeah sure so i'm i'm i'm still in
touch with my own dissertation advisor
um though these many decades later um
and um
so some of these relationships are
lifelong relationships and that's a good
thing
and i'm still in touch with many of my
own former graduate students again
lifelong relationships um in in the best
scenario
and um that's something that
becomes as kelly said before more
personal over time is something that
might start out as a professional
relationship becomes more of a
friendship and more of a pure
relationship and that's good to know and
i think that all of us
will always be in need of advice and
honest constructive feedback from people
and so the kinds of um
work that one does as a mentor or a
mentee is something that you're you know
you're always gonna want that with other
people um so it's not necessarily
mentoring once you're you know um later
in life you don't necessarily call it
mentoring but in some ways it's similar
yeah i can uh certainly echo that uh
i've certainly i've kept kept in touch
with a lot of my former students in fact
just this semester i had a couple of
students who graduated um more than 30
years ago
and get in touch with me for advice
about career moves that they they were
contemplating and
and uh yeah
and that's fairly common i that that
they'll that they'll get you know reach
out to ask about this or that um you
know so i think that's that's a that's a
good thing um in fact uh lifelong uh
connections are good i still keep in
touch with my own phd advisor uh who's
been retired for many years but i still
talk to him and get you know get insight
from from him occasionally
so yeah that's definitely uh
part
you know important to maintain
connections
um
one thing i'd add is actually we were
talking about junior professors uh one
piece of advice i have is
after graduating from phd and getting
your first job
especially if that's a as an academic at
an academics institution it's actually
very important as a junior professor to
get mentors
um
and and right now i think
i mentor several
junior faculty so our business school
recently set up a more formal mentorship
program between senior and junior
faculty
that started only two years ago and
before we didn't have the system set up
so in a place where the system isn't set
up it's really important to go out and
find your own people
in a phd program usually mentors are
assigned to you you're in a lab it just
the the structure is already there
whereas once you start your first job
that's when i think it's really on
the the new professors to go out and
find their own network
i'm going to skip around a little bit
because i'm going to try and keep these
um topically related um but so we got a
question
that's sort of related to what you were
just speaking to kelly which is about
actually forming a dissertation
committee but um how to approach
professors or find the right match but
also following the comment on tenure
versus tenure track um should we try to
have more senior faculty on our
committee would you recommend sort of
diversifying the committee so that
you're getting different voices
and
i'm reading into this a little bit more
but does anyone want to speak to that
i i didn't mean to imply that junior
faculty are not amazing advisors i was
just commenting on the institutional
design which is often they don't have
incentives to to do this although they
do it anyway
um in terms of forming a dissertation
committee
i think it really depends on the
specific people that you're considering
i think many junior faculty tend to be a
little bit more detail-oriented
so it actually helps to have some of the
younger people on your community so they
can look through
kind of specific things that you're
doing your dissertation your your exact
research methods uh whereas older people
might be better
on at framing or thinking about the big
picture now there are many exceptions to
this generalization
but that could be why it's useful to
have all sorts of people under committee
you know i think it's probably most
important to find the people
who you need and want to work with and
often that is a mix of junior and senior
you know
given yale's roles i think you probably
need to have at least one senior person
on a dissertation committee but
i think the most important thing is
finding
who's going to
who's going to help you accomplish what
you want to do and you figure that out
as you're doing your coursework
sometimes you come to graduate school
kind of knowing this is the person i
want to work with and sometimes that is
the person you work with and sometimes
it's not um but you know as you do your
coursework as you study for your
comprehensive exams as you enter into
writing the dissertation you figure out
who are who are your people and those
are the people you ask and i don't think
it necessarily matters so much about
junior and senior um it matters that
they're the people who are going to be
able to advise you
yeah i i can also say i don't think it
matters so much about junior and senior
but there are two things that i i tell
students when they're trying to decide
on their committee one is those are the
people who will know you best when
you're graduating and they're the ones
who write letters of recommendation for
you so you need to think about you know
what they might be able to you know how
they might be able to help you and
advise you in your career
path but the other thing is you want
people who know know the area well
enough to be able to give advice
and and so if you want to say well i
want the most famous person on my
committee because they'll be able to
write the strongest letter but if they
don't know they feel very well they're
not a good committee member so you know
we have a discussion in
when a committee is being considered and
you know what who who would you like uh
what and i would give back pros and cons
and uh so we finally
you know resolve and come up with a plan
for who who would be the best committee
members
so there's a question about how to
handle difficult situations with mentees
such as social discord with other
students productivity issues do you
sometimes need to be the bad guy or the
bad person in a situation um and i think
i would tie this back to also a topic
that came up earlier which is the sort
of like honesty of feedback
um and so do you all have sort of i i
would
be open to talking about it as sort of
needing to do this work in the best way
possible but also if there are difficult
situations that are more
um
take more care to
work through
um so yeah there are there are there are
a range of situations and
you know i think there are it's
different for different students in my
and and the way i
see it that
um you know as i get to know somebody i
get a sense of
how um
of how much i can push on them in a
sense that some people
are really open to being pushed and want
me to push them and some people are um
you know are maybe more sensitive to
being pushed and and i'm and i take more
care with my honest i've still i'm
honest with them all and i push them all
but some people i can be a little more
blunt with than with others and i think
that's a matter of that's the same you
know when in friendships and and with
your relatives you figure out different
people have different personalities and
you try to learn to work with them to to
you know to be supportive of them in a
way that will work for them and so it's
not always the same
but there are difficult conversations
and sometimes you have to have difficult
conversations and you have to you know
it's not necessarily pleasant but some
but you know you might you might need to
be involved in a difficult conversation
and that's okay
i guess uh i guess my thought on this is
that
the best way to uh to handle this is to
avoid it in the first place so foster
you know good relationships from the
very start and uh i think that can
oftentimes build a sense of teamwork and
collaboration that will make it less
likely that that will happen but you
know i think as joanne said sometimes
you know situations come up and the best
part best way to approach that is just
to be honest and you know face up not
not to let it fester and get worse
um for some of my students who have had
just the issues can range a full
spectrum but what has been helpful in
the past is actually
i've suggested a leave of absence
and that's been helpful just to take a
break from the university environment
it's actually viewed
perhaps better
to have a leave of absence
when you're searching for a job it's
kind of assumed that it was for personal
reasons rather than to have stayed in a
phd program for a very long time without
a leave of absence as you're sorting
through the same issues so i found that
could be quite helpful
other than that you know i
i don't view it as my job to be a parent
or to dress down a student so if some
student is really just not working
working harder or having some kind of
misbehavior issues i mean there's going
to be a limit i might comment on it once
but i'm not going to further
um dress down a student
i don't view that as my job
[Music]
thank you for that um
so um
there's a question about how could we
systematically
uh reward good mentorship at this
institution and i would
so we've started talking about this a
little bit kelly was sort of mentioning
this um so how could we do it and i
would also say
um what is rewarding about it
as three people who have received this
award there must be some incentive for
you personally
well i can say the biggest measure of
success i have is how successful the
students that have worked with me go on
and after they've graduated and you know
i think that's your legacy so that
that's where i would you know see my
reward is is the success of the students
that that worked with me
yeah i i agree it's uh it's not really
about direct rewards from the university
it's more it is
you know it's very fun and interesting
to talk to students about their research
ideas and to guide that process along
and i like to see how their projects
develop and where their careers lead
so that that's that's the reward
yeah i mean i i agree agree with what
both gary and kelly said and i i would
also say that i learn a lot from my
graduate students they work on projects
that you know it's not this lab project
where we're all working on the same
thing they work independently on their
own projects and i've learned so much
from reading their work and from you
know it's
i get to help shape a work i don't have
to do all the research um so i love sort
of reading their work and helping their
work along and i learn from that and
that's part of the reward for me the
relationships the lifelong relationships
that's important to me that's a reward
uh for sure and then there's then there
is the award that we all three got that
that was nice too so um so there are
ways that this is rewarding for sure
we sort of answered parts of a question
that just came in but there's a
separate piece that builds on what we're
just talking about which is how could we
facilitate improving mentorship skills
so i guess
my pre question to that is what do you
think the key skills to being a good
mentor are
um and then how would you encourage
graduate students to sort of build those
skills or faculty members to build those
skills
one of the things i would uh i encourage
um graduate students and postdocs who
are working with me is is to mentor
undergraduates and actually have an
experience and mentorship while they're
here and and we can work as a team to
learn how to do that effectively and
gain experience um i think once you go
off to become a faculty member you know
it's not cold you just have to start
learning how to be a mentor at that
point you can build build uh you know
your knowledge as you're going through
school
i guess i would say i would add to that
to be open to these kinds of
relationships to listen to listen is
really important
to be honest
to be of to just to um
yeah to be welcoming
those seem to be
things that are are important just sort
of in general and kind of in life
but i think they work in mentoring
relationships
i never got any training in how to be a
mentor i don't think that's part of
it wasn't part of the job search process
or part of the phd program
and i imagine most of my colleagues also
didn't get training in how to be a
mentor
so i here's where i think having
um
talking to multiple faculty members can
help we're all imperfect and we don't
have formal training
so it's it's useful for students i think
then to piece together what they need
across multiple different faculty
members
so we're coming on time and i know we
have a hard stop at one but i wanted to
offer you all the chance to give sort of
any last pieces of advice as graduate
students are thinking through their own
mentorship philosophies or other things
that you wanted to say during this
conversation that we just haven't been
able to touch on
well i guess i would say that you know
you are great observers and you can
observe your own professors now and your
own mentors and advisors now and that
will help you see what kind of mentor
you want to be um you know you will see
you will have people who um
you know have completely different
personalities than you do and maybe
their mentoring style wouldn't be your
mentoring style but you will find people
who are role models of sorts i hope
and you'll be able to pick up things
from them and learn how you know how you
might pay it forward i know i learned a
lot from my own dissertation advisor
just celebrated her retirement last
month
out in california and i know i i learned
a lot from her but she's a different
personality and i had to figure out
what is my own style of mentoring and i
did that partly by observing other
people and partly by knowing myself and
knowing what works for me
i can say that um i agree with that that
you you learn by observing and
in my case when i started out there
there were no mentoring programs we
never had yeah any formal mentorship
that i don't think that was even talked
about in those days but uh now so that's
now that's been put in place which is a
great thing but that's not all there is
you can
you can reach out to people who can
provide advice in there's both formal
and informal mentoring and in fact
informal mentoring might even be in many
cases the most useful for career
directions if you find somebody who is
you know has a career path or ideas that
help best fit with you what yours and
reach out and and
those kinds of informal mentoring can be
really useful
um i just like to echo something i think
joanne said about checking in often with
your mentors
i think this can be very useful
especially because students in the
beginning are are concerned i think
about making a good impression
and that leads to stress that actually
leads them to just not meet up with us
at all until they have made significant
progress on their dissertation
um i think that's unfortunate because
that can lead to a lot of wasted effort
in a in various directions
and actually by checking in with us
frequently
uh that actually allows us to to update
our beliefs so so one meeting in which
you didn't have uh your work done you
know it's absolutely fine as long as you
check with us you know regularly in
future months and throughout the year
and we can see the progress of the
project
great well i want to thank you all um
for your incredibly wise and judicious
advice today and just for being so
gracious with your time and insights
um and i also want to thank everyone who
participated in the conversation with
the questions through the chat um we i
should say that we do intend to post the
recording of the conversation on youtube
so um we'll get that link out to folks
soon
um and yes thank you all for being here
we really appreciate it and we look
forward to seeing you again soon